this is a production of Cornell
University
all right good morning again beautiful
day I think a little warmer remember
yesterday when we were out in in front
of the building back field we've got
pots come with the landscaping in a lot
all that and actually this area right
outside man library here was part of a
project that was led by Nina basak I
miss her earlier seats the she directs
the Urban horticulture initiative and
she has a class and in her class they
they take on a little project like right
in front of the library or in front of
another building and a amend the soil
like I said they bring in the compost
and the and the mulch and all that and
and then she's been doing that for I
know 1215 years and some point times had
had a grad student who make that a
project and then looked at the long-term
impact of the sort of remediation but
you can just do an you know anecdotal
assessment maybe when you have a few
minutes and on the break-ins walk out
here and see how how nice the vegetation
looks it really is all right so I'm
gonna talk about but some of the
research results so we you've seen the
our soil health testing or analysis
infrastructure and we over the years
we've done some research for that and I
wanted to show you the results of that
and give you some insights so one set of
experiments involve different tillage
treatments and we Bob and I started an
experiment 24 over 25 years ago
and we kept it going and so typically
when you go to a no-till or strip till
type system where you don't disturb the
soil you tend to see kind of an
improvement of soil health I mean just
generically speaking soil health as
measured by different indicators if you
do cover cropping you tend to see a
quicker response because you know when
you do no-till you just you don't you
don't
you slowly improve the soil by not
disturbing it when you you use a cover
crop or you apply manure compost you
more quickly because you're getting an
injection basically of biological
organic material to typically have a
faster response right at least that's
what we hypothesized and so we started
to include cover crops about five years
ago after we hired a new colleague Matt
Ryan who was an expert on that and he
has an interceder or to use that so one
of the hypotheses was if you combine
practices do you get more impact more
positive impact
are they really additive right can you
can you say that so that was our
hypothesis and so we did a whole bunch
of analysis using our sort of help test
and I won't go into too much detail but
let's first see what is the effect of no
tilling versus flowering and this is
more or less in continuous corn which is
really not an ideal system but we see
that for example aggregate stability
active carbon and protein we see a
fairly significant increase especially
with aggregate stability we saw a 92%
increase that's really good
if you don't disturb the soil and
especially you have a benefit with a
disability but also with these more
labile organic matter indicators active
carbon than air yes in question I would
say that works on just about every type
of soil yeah and this one will always
see their benefit from no-till so you
know with the special increases if you
yes yes if you do it right now you may
have some real challenges with no-till
on say more clay high clay content soil
and say sandy sort of but you'll see in
terms of sort of health you'll see
consistent benefits in fact we we had
some other experiments so this is a
lonely soil silt loam and we also had
experiments on clay loam soil and and in
sandy soil and we basically saw same
effect that we can maybe Joseph we
should
with some of those papers on the on the
box so yeah you do see those those
benefits now again if you if you go into
a no-till system you typically see it's
certainly a lot easier to do that on a
more sandy horse textured soil right so
for example that's on the Delmarva
Peninsula you see very high adoption of
no tell because the soils are really
quite amenable to that so let's so we
looked at they get an effective tillage
and now we have till it's plus cover
crops all right so this is plow Hill no
cover crop with cover crop and no-till
no cover crop and auto with cover crop
and you see that even after three years
we see that the there's an additive
effect of the benefits of the cover crop
so reducing tillage gives you an are
your stability organic matter but you
know by adding a cover crop you seen
this additional benefit which is really
nice you know because when we think
about my first presentation yesterday
where we're talking about some of these
cropping systems exporting a lot of the
carbon and the nutrients and so how do
you make up for that how do you how do
you keep that system sustainable well
reducing tillage bring in a cover crop
seems to be helping you maintain some of
that soil health now these are not
always significant but you know the
trend is definitely there and it was
only after a few years so I think that's
kind of good news right here's another
study this is working with the
announcement and North Carolina State
University they had a number of long
term till its trials like 26 years and
did some sampling sent the samples to
our lab and and things got analyzed and
this is was a very interesting study in
terms of the conclusions because one of
the real challenges with Sorrell house
is can you demonstrate that it increases
yields right because ultimately a farmer
might say yes oral health that's great
but how does it help me because there
may be some input cost you know cover
cropping
cost you money maybe cost you $30 an
acre right or going to no-till requires
investment in equipment so does it
increase the bottom line so I here this
graph shows you that the three different
tillage systems that were being used
conventional plowing no-till or it's
actually a minimum till you might say
and then chisel which is kind of an
in-between practice so what does this
graph show you here and shows you the
relationship between protein so one of
the indicators and tell us and you can
see that as you reduce tillage you
increase the protein content of the soil
based on ignore this for now so you get
more protein if you reduce tillage so so
it seems to be unfavorable in terms of
the protein content the second thing
that you see here is as Tillis increases
protein it also is associated with
higher yield right and these are quite
significant I mean the yields are is the
70% higher in the minimum till system
and it's also associated with higher
protein it doesn't mean that if you
throw a lot of protein on the soil like
whatever some waste material so that you
necessarily get higher yield but there's
in this experiment there's an
association between those now this is
just a tillage experiment so there's no
compost applied or manure or anything
else just tillage but we're starting to
learn that there are these associations
so it apparently matters okay now the
next slide will show many of these
things around in differents so the same
graph it's the relationship so this one
is the same mister as the previous one
the bars here are the variation in
yields and so it was a huge variation
from year to year
but there was a dry year or wet year in
North Carolina they kind of have that
and then these are the other indicators
active carbon manganese respiration
admissibility postures Megan magnesium
and organic matter so and I
ranked them right the one with the best
correlation was protein the one of that
showed before the second best is active
Carboni r-squared of 0.85 then manganese
and respiration at your stability and
organic matter so and these were the
indicators that were significant the
rest of them were not significant well
there's a couple of points here one
organic matter actually had a fairly
weak relationship with yield this is
with me Neil by the way while protein an
act of carbon so these kind of new
indicators have a much better
correlation with yield alright so that's
pretty significant so we're learning
that it's these labile organic matter
compounds in the soil that seem to be
more associated with increases in yield
and and we see those changes because we
have different toe systems and so Adam
gets the book so these three are these
biological new biological indicators and
they are the strongest relationship
manganese you might ask why manganese
right well manganese is involved in the
decomposition of organic matter it's an
electron exchange manganese 2 plus 3
plus it's an it's an it's a biochemical
process so basically manganese although
it's a chemical indicator it actually is
also so a green stability is the first
physical indicator with still a good
correlation but of course we know what a
magnetic facility is very much related
to these other labile organic matter
contents right and then we have these
other ones so this is a very interesting
experiment and we learned a lot one
we've we've been able to establish the
relationship between soil health
indicators and yield and we've been able
to establish that these labile indicate
indicator of labile organic matter seem
to be more important than organic the
total organic matter very interesting
right so here's actually these other
r-squared values what you see here was a
corn and soybean experiment here are the
r-squared values
or for the corn yields right then you
see the protein was good respiration
active carbon and manganese right that's
the one I reported for soybean yield a
lot of protein is actually quite weak
it's primarily the respiration and the
act of carbon so why is that why is soy
bean yield not as strongly related to
protein while corn yield is yeah it's
the whole because it's a legume and the
nitrogen and all that in protein
contains a lot of an agent so that gives
you some confidence that yeah that
actually makes sense all right but in
this case you see active carbon the mean
yields has a correlation coefficient or
0.93 right that's pretty high and it
actually was really quite high with the
corn as well there's the second highest
so active carbon appears to be a really
good indicator that correlates with
yield overall protein seems to be very
good correlator with yields of probably
grasses or non legumes yes that's what
we think yes I mean it makes sense right
yeah all right so here's another study
and Joseph alluded to it yesterday
briefly Wow
so we had quite a few samples analyzed a
few years ago over 3000 and now we have
a lot more and we'll show some more data
on that and I had a grad student I'll be
fine
and I said well let's make a comparison
between these three regions the
Northeast the mid-atlantic and the
Midwest so in a portion of Midwest we
have a lot of these grassland soils and
you know best soils in the world etc and
and so we were thinking oh we will just
have great soils there but let's make
these measurements of these soil health
indicators and then see how the numbers
come out and where where you see the
great box that means that for that
region that was the highest value or the
most favorable value okay so what you
see now let's take
right you see that the Northeast it's
about four minute line Achatz little
over four Midwest was only three
Midwestern soil on the average had 1%
less organic matter then the then
Searles in the northeast or mid-atlantic
and it's basically across-the-board
active carbon lowest in the Midwest
protein less than half right
respiration penetration resistance is a
higher number so it's less favorable so
this is really very surprising to us
that the source that we regard or the
region that we regard as having the best
soils turned out not to be so the
question was well why is this these were
the samples that we got into our lab so
we didn't really have a lot of back
problem but it seems like on the average
because in this region there's so much
export of carbon emissions like what I
talked about yesterday well in our
region we have a lot more dairy farms a
lot more organic farms but more
application of manure and compost and
things like that but on the average we
see that our soils actually for the top
six inches or actually better and it's
the same with the mid-atlantic right so
that's how some of our thinking came
about well we have to think about where
the carbon in the nutrients go if you're
in a corn soybean rotation it's row
crops and you export most of the carbon
and nutrients and it goes to China or
Mexico or Europe or place like that that
seems to be having a long-term impact
right so that got our thinking going on
this and actually Dave and I have been
talking about you know what that means
for new york with soil health and maybe
getting some of this carbon nutrients
from the excess farms like the dairy
farms to some of the other farms right
and jeana's gonna kind of talk about how
how we can do some of those things okay
so that's that was very interesting
since then joseph has been and I'm
presenting the data here but really he's
done all the work
on the credit for that so we now had
this is actually now already a year ago
we had a lot of samples from different
places and you can see some of the
states in New York of course we have a
lot of samples but we also from the
Midwest Iowa Indiana we have lots of
sample so even though we don't
necessarily have all the details around
you know the farms we have such large
numbers of samples that you can start
doing some interesting analyses and like
like I said especially for New York we
have you know many many samples that so
we can start doing some work on that and
we got some funding from the state of
New York that they've leads and so we
decided that we were going to do a more
in-depth analysis of New York soils and
try to relate that also to the different
cropping systems can we see some of that
out okay so this is what Joseph did so
we have we basically wanted to tease out
sort of a genetic difference in soils so
is it a clay loam versus a silt loam
forces along nice and and then the
management aspects and and so joseph
separated out five different systems
because we could do that based on the
crop code that came with the sample
submission so very faster mixed
vegetable processing vegetable and
annual crop right so processing
vegetable and annual crops tend to be
more conventional systems where a lot of
the carbon and nutrients is harvested
and exported off the farm dairy of
course tends to have an excess of carbon
and nutrients because not only do they
cycle the crops on the farm nose are
they harvest alfalfa and the corn silage
they also bring typically feed in from
other places last year is a system where
of course you have a lot of cycling of
nutrients and carbon and you don't
disturb the soil right and then the
mixed vegetable is a lot of those cases
that tend to be smaller farms typically
organic farms where they grow a lot of
crops
typically for farm stands or maybe they
sell it in New York City for restaurants
or places like that so and these are
typically organic so they use a lot of
compost especially compost and cover
crops to basically sustain the nutrients
and the carbon on their farm so they
typically have they they're typically a
scenario where they bring in carbon and
nutrients you know from compost from
other places okay so let's first see
what the differences are between
different textual classes right and so
we kind of you know because a lot of the
soils are used in kind of medium texture
we just have coarse two types of medium
and then fine and you see that this
organic matter for example for coarse
textured soil is only ogress 22.4 and
then it goes all the way up for a fine
Texas twelve to four point four why is
that why do fine textured soils have
more organic matter or anybody remember
yeah they have these bonds these are the
mineral bonds with the organic matter
right so the more clay you have the more
potential for for bonding with organic
matter and so it basically kind of seals
in the organic matter so we kind of know
that and that makes sense and we see the
same for active carbon more or less
protein and respiration we see that
basically as the texture is finer more
more clay you see higher values that's
why we interpret them differently that's
what Bob talked about yesterday in after
lunch so now let's look at the effects
of different cropping systems right and
let's start again with organic matter so
the processing vegetables have the
lowest percentage of organic matter and
then annual crop I'm more or less the
same number dairy farms had on the
average higher organic matter there's a
lot of manure that's being recycled and
all that but they also tend to do quite
a bit of tillage on these dairy friends
because they have to get the manure in
the ground and all that and mixed
vegetables those are the cases where
typically they bring compo
and then pastors was the highest right
and so these numbers so you're you're
talking you know almost you know but is
that eighty percent more organic matter
in the pastors than in D sorry I'm kind
of in the way there then the further
than the then the crops where you
removed most of the carbon and nutrients
so how is that for active carbon well
more or less similar numbers protein
yeah similar respiration okay doubling
available water capacity not as much
change you go from one point to two
point two five but I missed ability a
lot of change you almost triple the
stability of the aggregates in a pasture
system why is that you have cycling of
carbon and and no-tillage right so the
two things that that impacts the agnes
the most when you tell it it's bad for
aggregates and when you don't cycle
carbon it's bad for the aggregates all
right so that's really quite quite
interesting so if you see that you know
if you say you know somewhat a farmer is
in a say corn soybean rotation your
expectation of this of the health of
their soil should be different right and
so you can't necessarily so for a dairy
farmer if there was a matter for saying
oh that's sort of average right but for
processing vegetable if they're at four
that would be great because they're well
above average right so here's another
thing that we looked at and this is a
little bit of a statistical trick it's
called variance component analysis where
you basically say how much of the
variance is associated with the inherent
properties the texture how much is
associated with the management or the
cropping system right because that would
be interesting to know so so this these
numbers add up to a hundred so you're
looking at the total variability in the
system and for some organic matter about
an equal amount of the variation is
associated
next year for coffee system right so
that tells you something because when
you for example when we're doing soil
mapping you know we're mapping these
inherent we were talking about that this
yesterday morning these inherent soil
properties that we have to consider what
kind of a cropping system is that soil
in because it's just as important right
about to say for an active carbon I give
them a similar color
now for these labile organic matter
indicators protein respiration and
higher stability most of the variation
was associated with cropping system not
as much the inherent differences in soil
type from texture but more how is that
Cyril managed and remember from the
North Carolina study these indicators
were very strongly related to yield the
most of all those other indicators now
available water capacity is primarily
defined by texture that's the so is the
clays the sand
yeah maybe how you manage it is not all
that much impacted or doesn't all that
much the impact that available water
capacity so the point of this is is
maybe to one we're learning a lot about
soil health and what impacts our health
to is this issue of we have to think of
the anthropogenic impacts on soils from
cropping systems as being a very
important factor that when we think of a
sorta land we look at a soil map at
least a way to survive currently it's we
don't have all the information yet
because a Honeoye silt loam which is the
state soil for New York on a dairy farm
is not going to be the same as a honey
or so long on a kind of grain operation
or a mixed vegetable operation okay so
we have to start right it's like saying
humans you're you're human but you're
not sort of recognizing the
individuality of each person right so
you it's just general so the other thing
then that Joseph and I kind of worked on
and said well you know one thing maybe
that we can start doing is the set
goals called aspirational sort of health
goals so if we know what kind of a
cropping system you're in right we can
say for example if you're an annual crop
that you know you should be able to
achieve 3.2 percent organic matter
because that's actually the 75th
percentile of the distribution so we can
we can say you know this is a health
goal that you can access by them but
that health goal will be different for a
cash grain operation than a dairy
operation or a mixed vegetable operation
but we're we're saying if you are below
if you're a corn soybean farmer in New
York and you're below 3.2 percent you
can do better
we're not saying you should become 5%
because that would be unrealistic that
may be okay for miss Peck successful
operation but if you are a cash train
operation you should be able to reach
that point right so this is really
important from our perspective because
we do the same with water quality and
air quality we set these goals we said
you know nitrating ground water right
ten parts per million that's the
standard we say if you're above that
that's we consider them to be a problem
whatever the regulatory implications are
so we need to start saying okay if
you're this kind of a farmer and you get
this kind of a sort of Health Report
this is where we think you could be okay
like maybe your potassium level in your
blood or cholesterol level you could say
you know this is a reasonable point for
you to reach okay so that gets is
actually to another point and that's you
know there's a lot of interest around
Carbon Farming and actually in New York
there's people in Albany and our capital
or they're talking about it and so so
we're saying what we're starting to look
at with our data is to say look there
are certain soils that that have a very
little carbon right now and you may see
that as the glass more or less empty
right so maybe one of those corn and
soybean operations that have
maybe let's say 2.7 percent organic
matter you say well you have quite a bit
of opportunity to bring out that organic
matter level right so because the
storage capacity in the soil is own is
mostly on or close to us well this is
maybe more severely graded environment
maybe in Africa or someplace like that
so this is maybe a cash grain farm where
you say yeah there's there's some
organic matter in it but you still have
you can still fill up the glass more so
if you want to do carbon farming and you
want to sequester carbon into the soil
and and so that we can solve this the
greenhouse gas problem then going to a
cash wave farm would probably be good
right because if for some reason you can
get compost or manure on it it will stay
in the soil but many of the livestock
farms they basically already have very
high organic matter levels and there may
be exceeding the storage capacity of the
soil the glass is half-full you can put
more manure or compost onto the soils
but you're gonna lose it because the
glass is already full but it's just been
the organic matter mostly gonna just be
going off as carbon dioxide and the
nutrients are just going to accumulate
all right so if you're saying oh we're
gonna have a program Carbon Farming here
in New York you should think about you
know what kind of soils and cropping
system you're in so so that you know
that you don't say oh I'm gonna start
subsidizing dairy farmers to to do
Carbon Farming no because they already
have too much carbon on their glass is
already full now focus on these farms or
maybe even those farms so so here's
dosage analysis of you know we can look
at what is the carbon saturation level
for these different five different
cropping systems from our Cyril database
and so you can see that the annual crops
the corn soybean wheat and the
processing regular most of them are well
below that saturation point is the glass
half-empty scenario so if you were to
apply more compost or manure onto the
soils that would be great right because
the soils can take it they can store it
but you can see that the pastures the
mixed vegetables some of those farms
already are saturated with carbon and
nutrients typically so we shouldn't be
spending money on encouraging those
people to do carbon farming because they
can't they are already at capacity right
in this fight away is the equation that
we're using which is sort of the one
that most people use so so the ability
of the soil to store carbon is related
to the sand to the silt and clay content
okay maybe Joseph should I maybe stop or
I'm gonna skip this one okay yeah I'm
gonna skip print arrows work I think so
one of the things that we also were
interested in is can we make ourselves
better
we've been doing it and we actually had
been improving it for many years so one
of the things is if he if you develop a
simple sort of health test and Bob
talked about that a little bit yesterday
what are the most informative indicators
right which ones have we just already
learned about this morning which were
really good indicators like the ones
that are related to yield and all that
back to the carbon protein and all that
right so so we already have some some
ideas also maybe this but you know can
we estimate one indicator if we're you
know from the other indicators if we're
already measuring the other indicators
do we have - can we estimate one from
the other and then also can we use
reflectance spectroscopy this is one of
Dave's PhD students so what we did is we
did what's called the best subsurface
analysis we said if you measure only one
indicator which one is the most
informative and it turned out to be
active carbon alright so you can if you
look at all the indicators that we
measure and the overall sort of house
score did you get from that if you
already measured active carbon you
capture 60% of the variability that's
pretty good okay it's only one
measurement and it's a really easy
measurement to make you saw it yesterday
pretty cheap like what is it maybe about
$1,500
equipment maybe $2,000 and you know
pretty pretty quickly done so that's
really good news and we know that there
was a really good correlation with yield
as well so it's like that's a real
winner right if you say okay I'm willing
to measure two indicators active carbon
and organic matter would be best
Nick you know better prediction if you
say I'm willing to measure three
indicators active carbon organic matter
and respiration so these are all sort of
biological indicators labile organic
matter and total organic matter and then
four indicators then aggregate stability
comes in to that as well
so in a way this is good news if you
just want to do a really quick and
inexpensive sort of health test you can
measure active carbon and you can
actually get a lot of good information
all right so that's kind of good news
the other thing that that doors have
worked on you know we said have you guys
seen the AWC yet or not okay so
available water capacity requires these
pressure plates and it's about a $50,000
investment we had in my lab because I'm
sort of physicist and you have to have
that but it's really if you set up a
sort of health lot you know and here's
$50,000 active carbon is two thousand
dollars right so and it's kind of a
lengthy procedure it takes what we knew
about a week I think Bob forty and so
it's kind of a painting behind kind of
you know measurement and we also see
that it doesn't seem to relate all that
well to cropping systems or management
it's mostly defined by texture so random
forest analysis which is a machine
learning methodology and he was able to
predict available what capacity really
well with very low variability as long
as we measured these other things send
silt organic matter clay protein
respiration etc okay and so the ones
that are on top like sand silt and
organic matter and clay
and they were the best predictors so we
basically now said look we don't need to
measure
available work capacity more we can
basically estimate it from everything
else that we measure and we save
ourselves a lot of time so we basically
implemented that there's still a few
clients who insist on us using the
pressure plates but for everybody else I
think Bob we now put on the report we
say estimated or something like that
right yeah so so that was really useful
information for us you know it's saving
us a lot of money to always have also
looked into a grid stability and found
you know maybe somewhat similar result
not quite as good and you see that
protein aces protein and then organic
matter and clay and in respiration were
sort of the the biggest indicators we
decided not to estimate aggregate
stability we're still actually measuring
it with the the rainfall simulator set
up okay but you could if you if you say
really wanted to save money and have a
really streamlined sort of health
assessment you could actually estimate
your stability so this is this is Sonam
Sherpa who was a PhD student with Dave
here who actually worked with the the
Kellogg soil lab in RCS soil lab in
Lincoln Nebraska they had a lot of good
data using mid-infrared reflectance it's
it it's you're not actually doing any
wet chemistry you're just measuring the
reflectance properties the light
reflectance properties right so you can
like the colors but you go in to
actually remain ready and so and it's a
very interesting work in terms of
comparing the errors that you have with
this technique versus the errors that
you get with laboratory techniques and
basically found that especially for
carbon and nitrogen and clay content as
well you could do just as well doing a
very rapid infrared reflectance
measurement as actually measuring it in
the lab right so that's another
opportunity to speed up the assessment
so very interesting all right and I
think then that's that's it so a couple
of conclusions
overall maybe so one thing I really want
to I don't want you to take away is that
these anthropogenic spatial processes
whether we bring in manure compost from
one place to another
or whether we export you know grain from
a corn soybean operation out of China or
Mexico that actually does have an impact
on sort of health so and we've now
learned a lot about you know by by doing
these measurements and especially using
experiments we're really getting a lot
of insights in terms of what's important
it's our house
the first set of tools so we we also and
this is maybe something a little further
out so if we have these differences say
between livestock farms like a dairy
farm in New York and a new cast grain
operation on corn and soybeans wheat you
know then that means that those soils
are different and then when we start to
do agronomic research if we want to
learn about what kind of medicine
response you get or what kind of tillage
response you get they are different
soils we have to start taking that into
account you can't necessarily generalize
and say you your research on our
research farm here you know near the
campus and that never where you'll never
received manure and say oh we can really
just translate that to a field on a
dairy farm or a field on a mixed
vegetable operation that receives a lot
of compost right so we have to start to
become a little bit more nuanced about
the type of research that we do okay my
question is this is just this
environment effect and we encourage of
precipitations another day on the soil
health
so questions what what sort of
environmental circumstances impacts oral
health that's it's it's a good question
so we have this you know sort of health
differences due to climate through the
vegetation due to topography where on
the landscape er are you in a confluence
own are you you know on a hillside
temperature force makes a big difference
parent material so in this area here of
course we had a lot of we had glaciation
also an upstate New York and we had a
lot of you know impact from that in
terms of the minerals in the soil so
those are and we call it corpse right
climate landscape position or organisms
you know what kind of vegetation
precipitation and temperature something
like that so that's that's that defines
the initial qualities are the natural
quality of the soil and now we basically
see that under agricultural development
that additional factor comes in if
you're on a livestock operation you tend
to maintain or maybe even go up a little
bit but if you're in a cash grain
operation and row crop production you're
going to go down so it's this complex
interaction but it does mean that you
know if we interpret sort of health data
that you know a soil in say Alabama it's
not the same as a soil in Iowa to start
with right now you could make an Alabama
soil better than an Iowa soil but that
would be difficult right you can make
them you can really degrade in Iowa soil
and you can make an Alabama so much
better but only average of course the
Alabama soils will be different than say
the Iowa soil
you know but we're working on that so
we're actually we didn't really have
enough data to do that so we started out
with you know just one set of scoring
functions that we use to interpret the
numbers and then based on this study we
said well we need different
interpretations for a Midwestern soils
than the mid-atlantic and and so in our
paper actually those numbers are in
there now because we've collected the
samples from all over the country we're
gonna be able to say you know
southeastern soils need this kind of an
interpretation northwestern soils need
that kind of an implementation so we're
in the process of doing that
yeah one thing that NRCS has may be
aware of is major land resource area and
regions for example a region are up in
the Northeast
it covers parts of Northwest and
northeast Pennsylvania that rating your
innovation and they have similar climate
similar soil similar agricultural
practices right really that would be a
better way I believe to stratify this
instead of just you know the state line
these oils don't change right so if you
use these mlra regions their broader
still but yet have similar soils and
climates so that would be a way to look
thank you for saying that because we're
that's exactly what we're doing right
now so we're looking at the EM these
major land resource areas or the beyond
the llrs dealio Landry so yeah that's
the higher higher level yeah actually
that's how our soils when we're looking
at as a soil science on a major land
resource area soil scientists we cover
the glaciated Allegheny plateau and then
the glaciated Lake Erie Plateau so we're
our way the
we manage sales now and is based on
these mor aims right right so yeah
exactly we're completely aligned on that
maybe one more quick question yes well
we with no leads but less tillage we had
higher protein levels right so now keep
in mind it's an association it's not a
cause we're not saying that it's
necessary well I mean we have higher
protein levels when we reduce toilets
that's all we can say at this point in
time why I don't quite know yet I think
I have a pretty good idea because
proteins are a very labile important
organic matter that is they very easily
decompose as opposed to say lignin which
is very difficult to decompose so when
you till the soil then these these
readily decomposable organic materials
are going to be decomposed more quickly
right so in a way it makes sense that if
you don't tell you protect more of that
protein in the soil that's the
hypothesis that we have but you know
that would be an interesting thing to
study further you know at this point in
time we're just learning so much this
thing's that we'd never measured before
and then you say like wow that's really
interesting ok I endorse it back to you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu